what do you do again what do I do yeah
what do you do for a living I dance on a
PO no no don't really I I'm a singer and
I'm an artist okay well I would argue
that artists performers podcasters
social media influencers are are all
monetizing their looks you absolutely
have an advantage as a woman as an
Entertainer I'm just talking about being
the bread the bread in a relationship
what would say that what did you say
you're a podcaster you like podcast
monetize their looks oh yeah know I
think I think I I think I think I think
women have it easier I think it's and I
and I managed I could say this from
managing I I've managed social media
accounts for women and for men oh my
gosh it's so much easier if you're a
chick